on parle beaucoup de samir nasri à city
vous en parler dans les vestiaires où il
est un peu un peu parce que vous savez
que c'est des joueurs assez intéressant
des super joueurs comme nasri ou savez
on en parle beaucoup avec ses qualités
je pense que l'équipe va aller beaucoup
plus de l'avant mais bon on n'est pas
prêt si on attend je fait comme s'il
était bien j'ai dans le vestiaire bon on
espère un aspect bien on touche du bois
inch'allah on espère qu'il va venir
logement parce que c'était super jeu
pareil du second lundi
il faut pas être un génie pour pour
savoir que à ce moment là on veut tous
que sami androgènes en rigolant le
numéro 10 était aidé inteko et me disait
massive ou pas venir 18 qu'on lui donne
le numéro 10 parce que ça lui va bien
lionhead week-end display l'anecdote est
allée à l'aéroport de marignane et on se
posait la question avec avec mon agent
bon on fait quoi maintenant et c'est ce
qui est venue la discussion donc
l'argent de cheval en gagner peu importe
où tout ou tu signes - pas de problème
ok maintenant tu as deux choses soit tu
vas dans un club karine gagné depuis 48
ans et tu gagnes tu restera une légende
de ce club à tout jamais soit tu vas
united et délits gens que ce sera juste
un joueur parmi tant d'autres qui est
passé dans ce club-là
j'ai regardé un peu l'effectif sinon ils
devront traquer rodez déco balotelli tu
sais que je suis dans le monde a lancé
bass death au milieu du chemin trail qui
avec david tu peux combiner
[Musique]
2 qui contient des centres de tri
[Applaudissements]
prêché arrivé dans une équipe où dès mon
premier match on joue à tottenham on
gagne 5,1 je fais trois passes décisives
et le club que je vais quitter arsenal
d'en prendre huit à manchester united
[Musique]
à sa gauche samir nasri le vol avec le
ballon thaler
au portier baisser la mer toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la part de nasri vers aguero
dans ce sens
[Applaudissements]
me suis je préfère faire partie de
l'histoire d'un club et de marquer
l'histoire d'un club plutôt que
d'arriver dans un club qui la saison
dernière sans moi été champion
d'angleterre et après finale de ligue
des champions